that's everyone's nightmare either I'm a
psychopath in sheep's clothing or i M
you in terms of why they made a knock
story has captivated the world I think
that there are a lot of elements you
know there's an international element to
the story the victim who tragically lost
her life was was British Amanda Knox's
American it happened in Italy in this
beautiful picturesque town and everyone
has an idea of what Italy is like foxy
Knoxy it was a perfect headline reading
a perfect name all of the people that
were caught up in the story or you know
relatively normal people they they all
kind of became accidental celebrities
the film is really a collision of
personalities and worldviews and I think
that it's much actually easier to
understand this story when when you get
to know the people at the center of it I
think what you see in our film is what
amanda says she says you know people
love monsters they want to know who the
bad guy is and that it's not them the
legal outcomes have been debated for
years and the evidence has been debated
for years and so you know approaching it
from a different lens and looking at it
in a different way not as not as kind of
who did this but book more of a how did
this whole thing happen I think was was
our approach at the end of the day we're
hoping to kind of start a conversation
about how people consume these stories
and why we're also interested hopefully
the by seeing these people you get you
get some insight into that oh and also
you can kind of look at your own role
all of our roles and kind of this this
interest in true crime civilians
you